routine flight out of las vegas turned
terrifying for 56 people a sun county
airlines flight had just taken off from
reed international when part of the
landing gear collapsed and the pilot had
to make a pretty rough landing back here
in las vegas sasha loftis joins us live
tonight after speaking with a passenger
who described exactly what happened on
board sasha
denise and brian the man i spoke with
tonight gave us an idea of what it was
like inside that plane early this
morning he said it was really unlike
anything he's ever experienced and he's
glad no one was hurt
bam it was a huge bang where the landing
gear collapsed it's a terrifying
situation you don't often see
a commercial airplane making a hard
emergency landing we're
tilted
and sliding and skidding
and sparked flying matthew byron was on
sun country flight 110 from las vegas to
minneapolis early friday and he
describes the moment he first knew
something wasn't right pilot came on and
said
we have a malfunction with the landing
gear
we can't fix it with the computer so
we're going to have to head back to las
vegas byron says he didn't know what was
going to happen but he's grateful the
pilot was able to touch back down at
reed international safely just before 1
30 a.m the plane started to yaw a little
bit like it might pinwheel and he kept
it
on the ground kept it flat a sun country
airlines spokesperson issued a statement
citing an issue with the aircraft's
right landing gear
ceo jude bricker said the company will
take care of its passengers and crew and
is working with the ntsb to investigate
what happened still trying to process
the whole thing and get my head around
it byron tells us it's an experience
he'll never forget
and he's just grateful the situation
wasn't worse preparing for the worst and
hoping for the best
now that plane was significantly damaged
from that hard landing today and was on
the tarmac all day long as it did have
to be towed away ntsb officials they
were also out this morning inspecting
that aircraft at reid international
reporting live tonight sacha loftis live
local now